Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Lui è Walter, mio figlio:
ha quasi due anni.
Lo vedete così sorridente
perché appena scartato
il suo ultimo regalo:
un fantastico triciclo.
Devo dire che la risata di un bambino
è un suono meraviglioso,
uno dei suoni più belli del mondo -
a meno che non sia notte,
e voi non abbiate bambini.
Walter, in pochissimo tempo,
come tutti alla sua età,
visto la curiosità, esplorato e compreso
il suo primo mezzo di locomozione:
tre ruote che, una volta in sella,
gli faranno conoscere, per la prima volta,
il concetto di velocità.
Bastano pochi minuti,
e le avventure del piccolo Walter
si arricchiscono ulteriormente,
perché Walter scopre che la velocità
porta con sé dei rischi:
il tappeto ha bloccato
una delle tre ruote,
facendolo finire per terra.
Devo dire che, tutto sommato,
è una scena a cui siamo
abbastanza abituati:
qualche lacrima,
la ricerca di un abbraccio,
ed è di nuovo pronto
a correre più veloce di prima.
Se ci pensate,
le probabilità che un triciclo si ribalti
non dovrebbero essere così alte,
perché è un mezzo costruito
con l'unico obiettivo di dare stabilità
a chi si siede sopra.
È, nel vero senso della parola,
un mezzo sostenibile,
capace di rimanere in piedi
e di rimanere nel tempo
in quella posizione,
almeno fino al prossimo pericolo.
Ecco: quando parliamo di pericoli,
è sempre bene fare anche attenzione
al concetto del tempo.
Perché il nostro cervello
si preoccupa moltissimo
di tutti i problemi del presente:
ci mette tutta la sua energia,
la sua capacità di calcolo,
per risolverli.
Ma se il problema si sposta nel futuro,
per il nostro cervello cala drasticamente
la voglia di risolverlo.
Alcuni neuroscienziati
l'hanno anche definito con un nome:
l'hanno chiamata "Hard Empathy",
l'empatia difficile,
perché è come se, per il cervello,
un problema troppo lontano nel futuro
fosse il problema di qualcun altro.
È come se mi dicesse:
"Andrea, non è un tuo problema.
È il problema dell'Andrea del futuro,
lasciami tranquillo".
Se ci pensate un po',
è per questo che alcune diete
non funzionano;
le pubblicità contro il fumo
non hanno mai funzionato;
ma soprattutto, questo è uno dei motivi
per cui, anche se parliamo
di crisi climatica da decenni,
be', alla fine non abbiamo poi fatto
un granché per risolverla:
il problema era troppo lontano nel tempo.
Sono le tre ruote a dare sostenibilità
al triciclo di Walter;
e in effetti, quando poi
parliamo di sostenibilità
spesso la troviamo rappresentata
esattamente così: tre ruote.
Economia, ambiente e società.
Che si intrecciano, si intersecano
e in quella piccola intersezione
danno la sostenibilità.
Ecco: questa immagine
è completamente sbagliata.
È sbagliata perché ci porta a pensare
che possa esistere un'economia,
una società è un ambiente non sostenibili.
Che, ad esempio, l'economia sostenibile
sia una piccolissima porzione
dell'economia totale.
Ma essere sostenibili vuol dire
essere capaci di durare nel tempo.
Non è una questione etica o morale:
è puro istinto di sopravvivenza.
Ed è proprio per questo che,
se vogliamo che la nostra specie
sia sostenibile,
dobbiamo preoccuparci
di tutti questi tre aspetti.
Dobbiamo essere sicuri che l'economia,
per essere durevole, per durare nel tempo,
non si disinteressi
della società, del sociale;
e quella stessa società non deve,
assolutamente, trascurare l'ambiente.
Se vogliamo essere sostenibili,
dobbiamo occuparci di tutte
queste tre ruote insieme.
D'altronde lo abbiamo visto,
col triciclo del piccolo Walter:
basta che una delle ruote si blocchi,
che di colpo tutto si ferma.
La velocità diventa 0,
e il triciclo non fa più
quello che doveva fare:
sostenere Walter.
Anche se oggi è evidente,
che dobbiamo adottare
dei comportamenti più sostenibili
per durare nel tempo,
e nonostante il problema
sia sempre più evidente,
ancora siamo lontani.
Ma perché?
Beh, perché per essere sostenibili
bisogna innovare.
Bisogna innovare quello che facciamo,
come lo facciamo e il perché lo facciamo.
E innovare non è una cosa semplice:
innovarsi, l'innovazione,
è un percorso lungo, faticoso, tortuoso,
che richiede tantissimo tempo e soldi.
Lavorando, negli ultimi anni,
a stretto contatto
con moltissime multinazionali,
ministeri e organizzazioni internazionali,
ho visto che ci sono dei fattori in comune
che bloccano sempre l'innovazione,
e quindi non ci rendono possibile
la sostenibilità.
Il primo blocco all'innovazione
è la paura:
la paura dell'innovazione stessa,
del cambiamento, del nuovo.
Anche se ci raccontiamo
spesso il contrario,
cambiare le nostre abitudini ci spaventa.
Ci spaventa perché abbiamo investito
tantissimo tempo, e soldi,
per imparare a fare
quella determinata cosa;
non vogliamo che qualcuno, di colpo,
cambi il modo in cui la facciamo.
Facciamo un esempio:
immaginate che io vi dica
che domani cambierò
tutte le tastiere QWERTY -
che sono le tastiere
che utilizziamo tutti i giorni,
anche sul cellulare -
con delle nuove tastiere.
Le sostituirò nelle
vostre posizioni di lavoro,
siano esse a casa o in ufficio.
Le tastiere nuove
avranno i tasti posizionati
in maniera completamente diversa;
e lo faccio con un obiettivo,
che è quello di rendervi
più veloci a scrivere
e commettendo anche
meno errori di battitura.
Cosa ne dite?
Probabilmente, tutti voi
state pensando: no, grazie.
Sono abbastanza veloce
con la mia tastiera,
faccio pochissimi errori
con la mia tastiera.
Ed è esattamente quello che è accaduto,
perché il brevetto della tastiera QWERTY
risale al 1864.
Ovviamente, era stato fatto
per le macchine da scrivere
che sarebbero arrivate
da lì a 10 anni, pensate.
E sapete qual era l'obiettivo
di questo brevetto?
Rallentare la battitura,
in maniera tale che i martelletti
delle macchine da scrivere
non si inceppassero.
Ora, è evidente
che tantissimi altri brevetti
hanno provato a migliorare, innovare
il modo in cui scriviamo.
È evidente che è cambiato
il mezzo con cui lo facciamo:
oggi abbiamo i computer.
Ed è anche completamente diverso
il modo e il perché comunichiamo.
Eppure, la nostra abitudine
è stata molto più forte.
Il secondo blocco all'innovazione
è la somiglianza.
Se tutti quanti
siamo d'accordo in una stanza,
difficilmente verrà fuori
qualcosa di nuovo,
dalla nostra chiacchierata.
Ora, qualcuno di voi ha un giardino?
Alzi la mano!
Ok, io non vi vedo,
ma immagino che ci sia
qualcuno con il giardino.
Ecco: voi con il giardino,
ma anche noi senza,
sappiamo che per vedere un giardino verde
dobbiamo prendersene cura:
innaffiarlo, potare le piante,
difenderlo da parassiti e batteri.
Il che richiede, ovviamente, tempo
e anche competenze, oltre che soldi.
Se guardiamo invece un po' più lontano,
vediamo la foresta amazzonica
crescere verde
per chilometri e chilometri,
anche in assenza
di giardinieri qualificati.
Questo è possibile grazie
alla sua incredibile biodiversità:
tantissimi organismi diversi
che proprio grazie a questa diversità
mantengono in equilibrio
il sistema foresta,
un sistema in cui tutto è connesso.
Il problema, anche in questo caso,
è la velocità.
E già, perché se ci pensate,
per mantenere e creare
un equilibrio così diverso
c'è bisogno di tempo.
Con la somiglianza no:
la somiglianza è velocissima.
Pensate:
se dovete organizzare una vacanza,
di solito cosa fate?
Andate dalla coppia di amici
che ha i stessi vostri gusti,
con lo stesso potere di spesa,
con i figli della stessa età dei vostri.
E anche, se avete un problema,
andate dal vostro migliore amico
perché lui vi conosce, vi capisce
e quasi sicuramente vi darà ragione.
Ecco: il problema è che
la somiglianza è molto comoda -
perché ci permette di fare
le cose velocemente -
ma è un disastro nel lungo periodo,
perché sviluppa e determina
quello che viene detto un pensiero unico,
all'interno del quale
non cresce mai l'innovazione.
Il terzo e ultimo blocco
che ci impedisce di innovare,
per essere sostenibili,
è la disconnessione.
Disconnessione intesa come l'incapacità
di connettere e condividere
emozioni, idee, aiuti.
Le nostre reti sono
incredibilmente piccole e chiuse,
mentre dovrebbero essere grandi,
generose e aperte.
Anche in questo mi farò
aiutare dalle piante.
Eh già, le piante,
che non sono così solitarie,
e così silenziose, come noi immaginiamo.
Nel segreto della Terra,
le piante comunicano, commerciano,
scambiano informazioni e si aiutano.
Una fitta rete di radici,
connesse tra di loro da funghi.
Viene chiamato Wood Wide Web:
funziona come Internet, ma meglio.
All'interno di questa incredibile rete,
ci sono gli alberi un po' più anziani,
chiamati alberi madre,
che si prendono cura
degli alberi più giovani,
che stanno di solito all'ombra,
che non ricevono luce del sole,
mandando loro tantissime
sostanze nutrienti.
Anche gli alberi ammalati,
o in punto di morte,
cedono tutte le loro risorse
per far sì che gli alberi vicini
crescano più sani e più forti.
Non è finita qua,
perché gli alberi riescono
anche a comunicare tra di loro
quando c'è un pericolo:
si avvisano, fanno
fronte comune e si aiutano.
Ovviamente, come tutte le reti
che si rispettano,
abbiamo anche qui gli hacker:
è il caso del noce nero, che pensate:
quando si sente minacciato,
invia sostanze tossiche
agli alberi che reputa rivali.
Questo incredibile,
fantastico super organismo
che è il Wood Wide Web
ci dimostra come il continuo scambio
ci porti qualcosa
di incredibilmente positivo.
È l'ennesima dimostrazione che,
per essere sostenibili,
dobbiamo essere connessi.
Ora, tutto il mio discorso è nato
e si è sviluppato su un concetto,
la velocità.
Noi associamo alla velocità,
quasi sempre, un concetto positivo.
La consideriamo un pregio:
crediamo che essere veloci
ci dia più possibilità
di essere innovativi,
di essere più sostenibili,
di durare di più nel tempo.
Ma la velocità non c'entra nulla
con la complessità di una specie,
con la sua capacità di durare nel tempo.
Un colibrì batte le ali
80 volte al secondo,
ma non per questo è più intelligente
e sostenibile di un essere umano.
Noi non ci aiutiamo
tra di noi come le piante,
ma non solo per egoismo,
ma perché le nostre vite
vanno talmente veloce
che a volte non ci rendiamo neanche conto
di quelli che hanno bisogno.
Quando vai veloce, così veloce,
non riesci neanche
a osservare i cambiamenti,
a guardarli, ad anticiparli;
puoi solo reagire ad essi, velocemente.
Ed è quello che abbiamo sempre fatto:
abbiamo sempre cercato
delle soluzioni veloci
che ci permettessero di cambiare
all'ultimo secondo possibile,
che ci permettessero di risolvere
la questione sul filo del rasoio.
E questo ci ha fatto pensare
che tutto sia reversibile:
ma questa volta è diverso.
Questa volta non abbiamo bisogno
di una soluzione veloce;
abbiamo velocemente bisogno
di una soluzione lenta,
che duri nel tempo,
che ci permetta di creare
quell'ecosistema che supera le paure,
e supera le resistenze dell'innovazione.
Un unico sistema fatto
di tantissimi attori diversi,
ma incredibilmente connessi tra di loro.
Questa volta, mio caro Walter,
non abbiamo più tempo:
dobbiamo rallentare.
(Applausi)